snitch on the
toes singing If You Know It
morning Millennials I'm sorry I totally
[ __ ] that up like we literally
practiced 100 times before and I still
[ __ ] up just something about that
three two one I have to say good morning
we're like robots good morning
Millennials this is a very special
episode of the morning toast happy
Thursday Happy Day 13 in quarantine hope
everyone's doing well social distancing
as much as they can we are here with a
very highly requested guest she is
sitting six feet away from me
um it is the one the only the only
snatchler Our Sister Margaret [ __ ] on
the toast host of the iconic TNN podcast
the snatchler for all things Bachelor
related hi Margo thank you for joining
us today hi I love that I'm talking to
your back you know you're very much
behind me but people on screen can't see
that so how are you doing I'm good how
are you doing I'm good we really have
missed you here you are usually
um
well not usually but for the last year
besides for the last three months you
are TNN full-time employee every day and
Staples snitch on the snitch on the
satch like I'm new to this studio that's
so true what do you think isn't it
beautiful but you brought the sun with
you oh yes I did I think it's beautiful
it's very nice vibe in here very cozy
quite quite cozy we are so happy to have
you we're going to get into why you're
here today
um what allows you to be here okay how
are you doing
um how's your quarantine I've been
better
um my quarantine is is been good I mean
it's fine like
you know it's just been long you know oh
my God how long is it getting worse by
the day yeah I feel like week one of
quarantine we were all like self-care
you know taking time for ourselves like
this is a silver lining and now by week
two I'm like no no this is only me too I
have not washed my hair or my face since
Sunday and I just don't care I cannot be
bothered to like literally take a shower
now oh no you've got to whereas last
week you've got to shower herbs yes
Epsom salt like all that I had these
like ahava salts I'm like yeah it's like
self-care I'm a queen now I'm like all
right I'm getting in the tub scrubbing
my vagine and I'm out no but like the
shower is like my part of my day where
I'm like oh I'm going somewhere like I'm
doing I'm having a new sensation of
water falling on my face it is
Sensational it is Sensational
um we have a very exciting show we're
going to talk to this natural we're
going to recap our toast movie of the
day yesterday which was Beyonce's
homecoming and I have many thoughts and
we're gonna assign a new one to you guys
for tomorrow and I think you guys are
gonna like it it's something we've been
wanting to watch and a lot of people
actually suggested it thinking that we
would like it oh dude there yeah inter
Asante quite interesting so we're gonna
do our great show for you today um we're
gonna throw to the snitch cam a few
times because we have some show we have
some stories that we need to get your
take on okay um and then we're gonna
bring you in to the fold and we're going
to chat with you how does that sound it
sounds lovely also we're gonna cut to
snitch as much as possible because
Theo's sitting with her and he's back
and better then I haven't seen him in so
long so we're just like having him oh
he's off camera Margaret like just pull
him up into your arms for one second so
people could see him Dr Phil cheeman is
back he's been working on the White
House coronavirus task force but he got
the day off today he's exhausted I mean
it's just been sleepless night after
sleepless night and he and all the other
healthcare workers are actual Heroes and
I'm not joking about that like real
heroes yeah including Thea
um should we just like no it's okay no
no no no I was about to pull up my iPad
but it's only been three minutes and we
just have to like talk about nonsense
for as long as possible nonsensical
questions are some long days y'all so
um I have a question for you because you
know I've started to drink in my house
I've cracked and you've cracked um two
days in a row and last night I was
drinking from an opened bottle of wine
that was like a mega
it was like a beyond the average size it
was like double the size so I couldn't
really tell how much I was drinking but
last night I used mini bar by the mini
bar delivery app is still delivering
alcohol in New York just so everyone
knows I ordered three bottles of rose
and so I opened the bottle with my first
class and I finished the whole bottle
like the Magnum no no regular oh okay is
that crazy like I don't really drink
wine that much that's not so crazy
that's what happens when girls have like
girls night and you're like oh my God
that's like the song holding the bottle
yes oops no and by the way it's only
like four glasses heavy pores yeah it's
not that crazy it's like don't drink
tequila on the Rocks last night and then
throw up this morning that's right the
snitch is also hungover that's the life
update yeah that's a life update no but
I'm just thinking like okay so if I'm
gonna be drinking wine and quarantine
like I have to a lot one bottle for
myself every night that's expensive I
ordered three bottles of wine thinking
like this will get me through the
quarantine and I'm down by 33 already
yeah well you know what maybe you'll see
how much you're drinking and then like
next time you won't go for like the
nicest Rose you probably I did by the
way which would you do with spring Angel
it's only 19 that's a nice that's a nice
bottle of wine I thought that was like
the most expensive one but they were
that was the cheapest rose on mini bar
oh never mind yeah like they have the
you know mirror of all everyone loves a
mirror of all but the bottle's so small
but you know what you got to do what you
got to do to get through the quarantine
and if it's a if it's a bottle of Rose
at night it's a bottle of Rose that's
what I'm saying last night I actually
had fun like for the first time in my
life like I started drinking we did a
family Zoom oh my God we did a family
zoom and we were zooming for two hours
all scenes on Deck all scenes on Deck
it's like nice catching up with every
everyone like and by the way we didn't
even talk for half the zoom it was just
nice to feel like there were people in
my living room yeah it was really nice
we should do that again sometimes I'm so
down and then I got on another Zoom
where we played quiplash have you ever
played quiplash no oh my God it's really
funny
um I don't feel like explaining it but
it was really fun and so then I went on
Instagram live and I like danced for
everyone and I just actually like had a
good time and then she brought me in not
knowing that I was absolutely hammered
so now people are worried about me she
had the spins in bed I'm like what the
[ __ ] are you doing with the spins oh my
God what the [ __ ] are you doing putting
me on you guys are like now you said I
could you guys are now confirming like
my fears about drinking during the
quarantine oh yeah no it's terrible then
I'm gonna like feel like [ __ ] I'm gonna
have this imagine having this spins
right now as if things couldn't get
worse I know you know what I actually
feel fine like for having drank one
whole bottle of wine but I got in bed
again I was I started at seven I was
done at 10 30. I got in bed took two
Advil drink a bottle of water and went
to bed nice and a CBT gummy bear very
nice yeah treating yourself yeah I am
they're my favorite I actually really
like them and I thought I had run out
but when I was looking for my my kopari
CBD back cream I went to my CBD stash
and saw that I had more gummy bears so
then I ended up having more and they
were just everything of the sword I
don't really even know what they do but
they just make me feel good yeah I feel
like a lot of cbd's placebo like I feel
like here's my theory are you ready for
it CBD are you gonna theorize for us I'm
gonna see our eyes Okay CBD is to
marijuana
what caffeine is to Like Cocaine you
know it's like yeah definitely but like
caffeine is like oh my God I'm tripping
well some people actually are like very
I mean not IMM like I'm immune to Diet
Coke but some people like they're like
okay
and I feel like I'm some people have CBT
and they're like I'm feeling weird I'm
high yeah but that was me the first time
but I just like didn't know I was so
nervous to like get high I would love to
smoke some pot yeah actually I might
[ __ ] with CBD now that's a good call
yeah I have some stuff I was going hard
on my Essential Oils wow crazy time so
Jackie's house crazy times I've been
putting them in places crevices
oh my God I did something actually crazy
last night but I ordered an at-home
waxing kit and I'm gonna use it what
brand did you end up going with I don't
know something on Amazon that had the
most stars and I'm gonna use it is it
true it's a bowl and with beads and the
beads melt and they're strips Jack you
are never gonna be able to I'm gonna I'm
gonna try it where are you gonna do it
on What armpits I'm gonna first I'm
gonna try it on my hand to make sure the
temperature is good and that it works
and then I'm gonna do my armpit do you
want me to do it maybe that would be
just like a fun New Sensation that's the
craziest thing I've ever heard I'm just
looking for New Sensations which is why
I read the book little fires everywhere
so I could have the sensation of
watching the show yeah and comparing and
contrasting yeah convince me to get a
LoveSac yes I got the same monitor I
have absolutely no space for it and no
idea where I'm gonna put it but it's
quarantined so like things are just up
in the air and I'll just leave a LoveSac
in my hallway right I have like a Love
Sack next to my bed it makes absolutely
no sense there but it's like a nice
place to chill yeah I just need more
places to move around I fell asleep in
my LoveSac two days ago and like when I
woke up it was like I was in a coffin
could you get up it was it was
disorienting as hell yeah honestly I
wouldn't recommend falling asleep I feel
like that would be like you falling
asleep in like um a foam ball pit you
know like in gymnastics those things are
[ __ ] impossible to get out of it if
you lose a sock like you'll never find
it again that's actually took a picture
of me sleeping in it and the way that
I'm positioned it looks like I'm just
like sitting did you fall asleep on your
back yeah and I put my legs up on the
chair so I was just like laying it was
very comfortable it was a little too
comfortable sounds like you're imagining
you were in a pool you know like a raft
yeah like dreaming that's exactly what
it looks like with my arms up yeah gotta
I could have been holding like a can of
soda oh my God literally I just wish I
had a pool like I keep on my Instagram
live like asking people who are like
quarantined in their houses like how
their pools are and it's just so
fabulous how are their pools but then
I'm seeing some people in their pools
and their pools are covered and like
they didn't get the woman to come oh wow
that's so sad at least they have a
backyard and can get some fresh air it
depends where you live though like in
L.A I think that the pools stay open
year round but in Nashville it's not not
the same you know it's not the same I
just wish I had a pool like I would be
[ __ ] diving and [ __ ] I wish we had a
backyard so bad I wish we were in a
house right now and that's what we've
been saying like I've been craving a
fireplace what have you been craving in
your quarantine counselor snitch I've
really been craving like fresh air and
like just having more space to move you
know like other balcony I know but it's
just not the same I'm staring at
buildings yeah and like dirty New York
air yeah I wish you had more space for
activities is that what you're saying
yeah like if we have like a nice
backyard we could play some soccer well
maybe if we put our beds on top of each
other we could have more space should we
build it for
yeah I mean literally any sensation I'm
down for I'm just down for like
stimulation like both physical or mental
like I will genuinely take what I can
get but I'm a I'm about 30 seconds away
from just hopping on the subway just to
speak to someone you know I don't think
anyone would be like people there
there's definitely people in the subway
New York's crazy like it's not people
around me it's really not I'm actually
so impressed with the city like the
level of calm and just the following of
rules that people are displaying I think
it's fabulous yeah I'm Sensational it is
but
um it's also making it really scary at
night because New York is like usually
this Lively bright lit up place and if
you go out at night which I don't but
Ben does to walk Theo it's scary like
you never really see what New York looks
like in the dark but if you want to go
outside of midnight it's the city that's
sleeping now that's for damn sure it's a
city that doesn't stop sleeping yeah
we're just asleep at the wheel yeah well
speaking of sleep actually this is a
good time to give a programming update
because we've decided that next week uh
for the morning toast live show we are
going to start going live at noon
instead of 10 30 that way people on the
west coast can also watch us live
exactly and that way our day is shorter
um and we can sleep more yeah selfishly
like I'm most excited about being able
to sleep like two more hours
um but also I never realized that our
live stream goes live at 7 30 on the
west coast and if you're
maybe not even awaken at your desk
definitely during quarantine you're not
so more people will be able to watch and
to be honest like when we get done even
yesterday we did such a good long show
and it was barely 12 o'clock we have so
much a day ahead of us and there's no
why are we waking up so early like it's
like for who yeah we're making our own
daylight savings time yeah so I hope
everyone's okay with that quarantine
savings time we're on qst yeah it's a
special time zone
um so yeah same Everything YouTube
podcast but just 12 o'clock Eastern time
and we hope you can understand why and
if you can't I genuinely don't care so
yeah it'll be it'll be even better I
love an afternoon show makes me feel
like we're in La yeah like maybe I'll
have a drink
oh my God you guys should do that like
it's just a drunk show we should do a
drunk show it's literally like you don't
have to ask me twice we are a drunk show
that's true we're drunk on steamy Vibes
oh yeah not as good as being drunk on
alcohol but close I don't know sometimes
those teeny Vibes they're intoxicating
actually Sensational that's true
sometimes they are quite sensational
they're especially Sensational that was
a crazy laugh when we've got the snitch
in town
it's just back in town it's just not
fair like you're literally looking at
Margot and my back is completely towards
her I feel like it's rude I know maybe
like you should switch seats with her
and then she was in the middle and we
could both talk to her but then you
would be on the quadcam you know and
then it's also like yeah
move the chair so I feel like we made a
conscious decision if I said I think it
should we had made a conscious decision
to segment Margaret till again and I
know we can't stop like talking to her I
know she's just so Sensational that's
true
um so just breathe through let's get
through let's get through it let's just
start okay let's just start because the
sooner we start the sooner we can move
snitch's chair over here and look at Dr
faucyman they can't see him let me get
eyes on the vouch honestly I think he
should come to one of us because he they
can't see him on Market but he's so
happy it's all about fauci's happiness I
just miss him I miss him so much okay
let's start let's let's get right into
it because without further Ado et's time
for the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and that's true and you know we just
want to get to Snapchat so I'm not even
going to come up with a creative way to
let you know that this ad I mean that
this show is who sponsored by Yamaha and
they've been sponsoring a lot of the
shows this week and we really thank them
and they're letting us know about great
work from home products that you might
not know about Yamaha has been focused
on audio for over 130 years when you're
working from home relying on laptop
audio can lead to a poor audio
experience it can result in
misunderstandings frustration and even
stress or fatigue keep your teams
functioning at a normal level Yamaha is
here to let you know about one of their
portable speaker phones that should be a
no-brainer in your work from home kit it
is a discreet and compact device that
you could throw in a bag or take
anywhere it's packed with technology to
make you sound great on conference calls
and block out any unnecessary background
noise it even has easy mute buttons if
your dog is barking Theo doesn't bark or
if your husband is bothering you he does
do that a lot um sometimes you know a
siren might be going off we've
experienced that and that's why the mute
button is great you can connect to any
software with this device you can
connect to zoom Skype or Microsoft teams
and you can even listen to music or the
morning toast between calls give
yourself and your teams the right tools
to collaborate and keep your business on
track because yamaha's teams are full of
toasters we are able to give you a 10
off code for all of their work from home
devices visit
uc.yamaha.com toast for more information
again that's
lettersuc.yamaha
yamah.com toast thank you Yamaha for
sponsoring today's episode of steamy
Vibes and sensationalism
love it first story the big story of the
day it's it's bittersweet news for the
toasters because Ariana Grande has a new
man and he's not Jim Carrey no but he is
Pete Davidson um just with Pete Davidson
Pete Davidson businessman Edition yeah I
mean I don't all I saw was this photo of
him who looked like an actual 19 year
old so I don't know if he's technically
considered a businessman Beau but all I
know is that he's Pete Davidson with a
new nose well he's a real estate Big
Shot according to TMZ and and I would
consider that in the businessman bow
category oh for sure I just saw a
picture and it looked like hi I just
graduated real estate school let me go
get my picture taken five years old let
me go get my picture taken at the real
estate office he's got a young patch
love to see it I just I'll say I've said
it once and I'll say it again like
Ariana Grande continues to disappoint me
in her selections of men
um like who what's his name his name is
Dalton Gomez uh TMZ sources tell them
that she and Dalton have been seeing
each other for several months now he's a
high-end real estate agent who handles
multi-million dollar listings for LA's
A-list buyers does he work at the agency
because if he doesn't not interested uh
not that I'm aware of but he is also the
guy that she was making out with that
time when she was in a recipe with Jim
Carrey okay also this is the biggest
point I think quarantining together so
this is actually big stuff they could
The Way Ariana moves they could be
married by the end of the quarantine I
mean I think a lot of people will be
married by the end of the quarantine
like quarantine days are like it's like
dog years yeah I know we were really
holding out hope for Jim Carrey and
Ariana Grande and I just want to say to
me this news story doesn't prove that
they weren't ever momentarily together
yeah and I feel I feel like maybe you
know maybe she has two boyfriends like
who knows get you a girl who could do
two boyfriends maybe she's quarantining
with one like she needs someone to hang
with but like Jim Carrey like she
doesn't want to ruin that relationship
yeah I would quarantine with the person
who I'm happy to ruin my relationship
with yeah or like the person who you
don't really care about like you want to
see me like when I wake up sure whatever
yeah you want to like know when I'm
going into the bathroom and how long I
took in there fine that's that's on you
Thomas what's his name his name is
whatever
um speaking of going to the bathroom in
quarantine um snitch is there something
that I want to talk to you about right
the quarantine crew and I don't know the
taking of dumb situation for the girls
and the guys because I'm literally
having anxiety about it is
can you share with the toasters how many
people are in the house Margo I believe
it's six it's a lot of people so can you
share with the toaster some of your
concerns about the quarantine crew other
than the fact that they're not properly
social distancing if you don't know the
quarantine crew is Tyler C and his
family and Hannah Brown and like their
friends all quarantining in the same
house in Florida yeah no I mean it's
definitely like weird I just there's so
many questions that I have about it
because it's like makes me think that
Tyler and Hannah have been dating a lot
longer than we think like how do you
just all of a sudden get along so well
with someone's best friends like that
doesn't happen that quickly
um the quarantine it does that and then
quarantine together like in a frat house
it's a frat house it's a friend I
actually read in the toasters I think
it's Tyler's mom's house that's what I
thought too I just like using comments
it's important to note that it's a three
bedroom and there's six people oh did
you find the Zillow listing someone did
yeah
[ __ ] nuts oh my God that's the
information we need three bedrooms six
people two to a room except for Tyler
and Hannah sharing or is it girls boys I
think the bathroom situation Tyler and
Hannah even if it's girls boys there's
one co-ed room
right by the way of course Hannah and
Tyler are together like people are like
do you think they're together no they
literally just posted one million videos
of them they're spending the whole week
together touching each other of course
they're together like there's no mystery
I don't know there's something like so
friendly about it no you know
something's just so like
weird about like
the fact that they weren't together and
now they're quarantining together that's
what's weird like you don't just jump
from being friends with someone to like
quarantine that's why I agree with that
that's why I'm saying I think they've
been together longer than longer than we
know damn stature with the fact but I do
think a bathroom wise there's definitely
a girl's bathroom in a boy's bathroom so
the girls can dump in peace and the guys
can dump them they need an outhouse do
the Zillow listings say how many
bathrooms are in the house it probably
did but I didn't look but I would assume
I think three bedrooms two bathrooms
make sense maybe two and a half or one
and a half maybe they're all sharing a
shower but they have no way so
interesting I mean that's my worst
nightmare like I I hate taking like
group trips with people who are not my
family because I'm just like so weird
about like my stuff and like my toilet
time and like my shower time and I just
don't need people like looking over my
shoulder you know like at how long I'm
dumping for of course I mean that's
really been like my cross to bear
throughout my life but so can you
imagine being quarantined in that
situation like all right a group trip is
like a weekend a weekend you know but
yeah I would never put myself in that
situation I'm just not that kind of girl
I'm not that kind of girl I'm okay I'm
also just not the type of girl who like
wears a bikini in shorts and like Cooks
eggs you know oh it works out every day
like and jumps into a pool being filmed
on slow-mo yeah yeah I'm just I'll never
be that girl and you know what I'm
genuinely okay with that yeah same Margo
I feel like at some point in your life
like you were that girl yeah probably
but like not anymore you're like the
closest of us to being that girl but
you're still not that girl I'm still
never gonna you're still like I'm not
even close I'm still never gonna be
filmed in slow-mo in a bathing suit like
you actually couldn't pay me jumping
also like it Margo I feel like you would
also just never cook eggs like in a
bikini because like it's like not that
hard to like put a shirt on you know
yeah yeah and also like cooking is
dangerous like the egg like that no and
like next Oil flies next to a completely
full garbage can oh I saw that too also
by the way like
I just think like the quarantine crew is
creating content but they need to start
cleaning up after themselves because the
house is getting dirtier and dirtier
with every tick tock video they put out
and it's just like kind of gross like
there are girls and boys living there
like I know that boys are messy but like
girls like you clean up clean everybody
every chair clean up clean up everybody
everywhere I don't think that's how the
song no me neither we're confusing it
with
also they're not even drinking which is
like the most concerning how do you know
that like I just feel like you we would
see it or know it like I haven't even
seen a red cup oh no I totally disagree
I think they were have been drinking the
whole time they were playing that beer
pong game virtually on IG live with some
athletes rice
Halls oh another sway house oh yeah
there's like all this drama but wait
also Mario I guess those people aren't
21 so they probably all weren't drinking
but like they were but they were
pretending like they were Margo they're
definitely drinking I've been seeing
like red wine everywhere and Hannah has
had like red stained lips and like a
bunch of Snapchats and stuff okay red
stainless like red wine you know when
your lips turn like a little red yeah
yeah they're totally drinking I hope so
I hope so if they're not what else are
they doing because they're not cleaning
the house
okay next I just want to like literally
send like a maid service over there like
complimentary it's on us it's on the
toes Blake please If You're Gonna Keep
if your content is just gonna keep
blowing up and like it's going to be all
over every website and every social
media platform like I just want to see
you in a clean house
yeah no I totally agree it's not
something like a good example for like
these kids who look up to them who are
like don't understand the importance of
like being in a clean face while you're
quarantining I mean no it's really
important for your mental health like
clean your house change your sheets take
out the trash that is so [ __ ] true
and I literally cleaned my house five
times a day because I live with Ben it's
so important okay and especially like
when you're in the new relationship like
I just just I can't and they should and
they win next up similar story Batcher
Peter Weber hangs out with ex Kelly
Flanagan after split from Madison Pruitt
okay a picture went viral on the
snatcher Instagram last night that's we
are why we are so glad to have you here
today I mean yeah I just love that like
I was so hammered last night and I
somehow found the time to post that
photo go snatch look good yeah she never
stops I don't even remember doing it so
the context is basically Chicago Peter
is somehow in Chicago because he lives
in L.A and don't know how he got there
that's where Kelly lives they were
spotted like on a dock somewhere he was
throwing her over his shoulder and it
was like super cute but there are many
questions one of them being why aren't
they social distancing and that was like
the most controversial thing about the
photo you know it wasn't that like he
broke up with Kelly another back
together it's like why are you outside
right but also why is Kelly lying yeah
she lied
oh she lied on my live stream oh she's
like no I like really haven't spoken to
Peter and like we're not bad would you
get back together and she's like no like
it's done so I wonder if she like was
genuinely telling the truth in that
moment and then like he texted her
moment my live stream ended or she was
straight up lying to me I choose to
believe the former yeah you know what I
trust her she's like a trustworthy girl
and whatever she's doing like I trust it
and everyone is really coming down on
them for like not social distancing but
like I don't understand how it's any
different than like everyone else who's
putting out con like the quarantine crew
right because the quarantine crew was
quarantining from their dirty house
in public they were like they went for a
walk no but I saw another picture of
them like sitting on some steps with a
bunch of other people look at them I
didn't see that yeah so people are just
like but it's very possible they could
be have been quarantining each other for
14 days no one would have known because
they're in their house together and then
they went out for a walk you know they
got just like exhausted so we think
they're 100 together because sometimes
like pictures like this come out and
it's like oh no we're just friends I
mean literally not that I would ever let
Ben do it but I would not let a strange
man throw me over his shoulder yeah yeah
it's such a bachelor move like honestly
the photo was a little suspicious like
he was kidnapping her you know
maybe that's what this is a cry for help
a kidnapping then we're just all being
like yeah ship yeah yeah but it's like
someone said someone's life is in danger
wow Margot do you feel like
um they'll end up together this is just
like some weird thing you'll never get
an explanation for I just don't like see
it at all I don't think that Peter I
always said that I don't think any of
the women in Peter's sees him and are
meant for him like I just don't think so
who he thinks meant for him you no I'm
so done with him
I know I did I really did think Hannah
Brown to be honest so now I I actually
did think that too
me too wow wow well the statue is spoken
and that's that that's that well you
know what I I ship happiness for Kelly
and if this is it I'm happy I agree with
that and she's a smart girl so whatever
decision she's making she's not thirsty
and she's not desperate so we'll see
yeah okay next story
um Lala Kent has taken to Instagram with
an original song I Saw called a million
germs set to the tune of a Million
Dreams from the greatest showman which
is one of my favorite songs and she's
one of my favorite girls
um and it's not one of my favorite
things that I've seen but I actually
thought it was hilarious she looked
beautiful first of all like no makeup
her hair was snatched like her skin is
so good I like that she was like getting
creative on Instagram I actually follow
her on Instagram and I feel like I don't
know her at all from her Instagram I do
wish she doesn't care about it which is
cool but I wish she did and like was
putting more effort in besides just like
pretty pictures of her and
um give them Lala Beauty yeah so I'm
loving that she's leaning more into
social media and I don't want to
discourage her but this song was just
nothing of the sort oh I disagree it was
something of the sort like there were
some lyrics that I was like no but then
there were some that I was like oh my
God that's hilarious and I mean she was
obviously inspired by your husband Ben
Soffer who's been writing original
quarantine songs for a while now he's
working on a new one and I have to say I
think of all the content he's ever made
and he makes a lot like a lot that was
by far my favorite piece of art from him
me too I mean if I hear that song one
more time I'm literally gonna blow my
brains out because literally you don't
know how many times
I don't know how many times he recorded
it and then by the way when he finally
came up with the one that he wanted to
use how many times had to listen to him
like replay it he was putting the
captions on and were you filming it of
course no oh how did he film it he has a
tripod
um he's working on new material um I
think he's going to do a uh quarantine a
new quarantine song to the tune of
when I am down and oh my soul so weary
it's his favorite song because he
actually sings it very well oh that's
nice except it's a little triggering
because we were supposed to go to the
Josh Groban concert in April and now
we're not and you know we're also
supposed to go to Vegas oh yeah I know
but like we had a I don't know some q a
of who would you want to see in concert
that you've never seen before and my
answer was Josh Groban and that was
gonna happen for me and now it's not who
would you want to see in concert that
you've never seen before counselor
snitch oh damn that's putting me on the
spot I need to think okay should we
should move oh my God Garth Brooks he
said really apparently his concerts are
like Sensational oh Sensational like
he's an incredible Entertainer and he
just like doesn't leave the stage like
he doesn't they're like three hours long
and he releases all these tickets for
like 50 bucks each but people resell
them for like three thousand dollars but
it's like it's equal opportunity he's in
egalitarian love to see it he's also
been going on Instagram live like and he
wants to stop and he has to stop no and
I love these people and the only person
who's I actually enjoyed was Luke Combs
but me too I watched it on my TV yeah
fabulous because he put it on his
YouTube yeah and he's one of my
preferred channels
and then I watch it on my TV I also
watch Morgan Wallen who by the way I
just I love him yeah I've been listening
non-stop when I'm drinking my bottles of
wine um to the hot country playlist
which really just lets me know like
what's popping in country and Morgan
wallen's all over this bar is so good
cover me up yep so good also all over
the hot country playlist is Lauren Elena
and she literally if she genuinely tried
to put out a bad song she would fail I
completely agree that song one beer with
Hardy is so fabulous her EP is fabulous
in my veins
she's just fabulous yes totally fabulous
much like lala Ken who I really
appreciate her originality she's
obviously cracked and quarantined love
to see it
um and I love the respect for a great
song we officially canceled our trip to
Vegas last night I did get a refund for
my flights for those wondering I
canceled my flight on the Delta website
and they gave me a full refund in the
form of a credit which is fine because I
fly Delta all the time and whatever but
we actually did a United and a Delta
flight so United gave me the same thing
but like I don't know a United Credit
just like is annoying but I'll find a
way Fina was really shady is that United
gave me a refund for one year from the
day that I issued the ticket not the day
that I got a refund so it's like 10
months not 12. so should I stay so
shysty Amber so should I stay so Shy's
tea okay next story speaking of
um living room concerts I heart living
room concert for America is coming to
Fox oh interesting wait what does that
mean so I heart um is putting on a
series on Fox on TV called the living
room concert where artists are going to
film themselves like how they've been
doing for IG live um they're going to
film themselves in their homes in
quarantine and put on concerts that will
stream on TV some of the artists
participating are Alicia Keys Billy
eilish Backstreet Boys Tim McGraw how
are they gonna do the Backstreet Boys
they're not all together are they you'd
have to be succeed apart Billy Joe
Armstrong Mariah Carey and it is hosted
by Elton John oh so it's Elton John I'm
just gonna be alone on a stage it'll be
Noah she's gonna like be in his living
room throwing to someone else in their
living room yeah I mean honestly this
only works if the tech is superior and
after my experience watching CNN for the
first time I now know that major
television news networks do not have the
capability to live stream people in like
they cannot figure out how to use Skype
and I'm worried so this sounds fun and I
would participate if if they get their
technology right you know the hour-long
commercial free benefit concert will
shine a light on Frontline workers amid
the pandemic and encourage viewers to
donate to two Charities feeding America
and First Responders Children's
Foundation that is fabulous I love that
has a philanthropic element I will
definitely be tuning in it will air on
Sunday March 29th on Fox at 9 00 PM
Eastern Time 6 p.m Pacific time it's
been a while since we had to benefit the
original slot for the iHeartRadio Music
Awards before it was canceled oh well I
this is the kind of shucking and jiving
that I love to see me too I love that um
there's a philanthropic element and I
feel like we haven't had one of those
benefits in a wildlife members stand up
to cancer of course an iconic benefit
where all those women got together and
Rihanna had like spiky hair man keeps
telling you don't give up we're like
those women singing we sound so good
yeah we sound so good Miley was there
with her long hair everyone was there
everyone was there I'm looking forward
to this I'm looking forward to this as
well and it's like something we can all
watch together like as a nation I hope
they raise a lot of money one nation is
it a story about Kylie's million dollar
donation that's my fifth and final oh
okay because I have some other donations
I want to shed some light on oh actually
let me grab my phone so I guess it's
time for our fifth and final story
because the sooner that it's time for
that the sooner we can move snitches
couch over Kylie Jenner donates one
million dollars to help fight the
coronavirus pandemic Kylie Jenner
continues to do her part during the
coronavirus pandemic the 22 year old
billionaire with the B has donated one
million dollars to help in the fight
against the deadly virus sweeping the
globe the money which she donated to her
OB GYN will help fund the cost of
hundreds of thousands of masks face
Shields and other protective gear
love to see it you know I posted it on
our
um Instagram and I saw like two comments
of people being like only a million
dollars like that really rubbed me the
wrong way and they were like it's
technically equivalent to like the
average citizen giving a hundred dollars
which by the way is very generous for
the average citizen right if every
citizen gave a hundred dollars we'd be
in a great spot I just thought that was
like and I saw just a lot of people with
the sentiment it's like she's a
billionaire that's all she gave I'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me you give a
million dollars [ __ ] yeah no you give a
hundred dollars yeah it was just so like
I can't believe that Kylie can't win no
can I [ __ ] win
um I wanted to highlight some other uh
celebrities who have donated money
because pop crave has a thread on
Twitter
um Sierra Wilson Sierra and Russell
Wilson announced that they'll donate a
million meals to the food Lifeline an
organization that distributes food to
shelters food banks and meal programs
Ryan Reynolds and Blake Lively announced
that they're gonna donate a million
dollars to food banks amongst amid the
coronavirus Kelly Ripa and Mark
Consuelos also donated a million dollars
to relief efforts
Rihanna's non-profit will donate five
million dollars to address the needs of
families impacted by the coronavirus
pandemic now I'm bringing the money down
a little bit Shawn Mendes helps his
hometown of Toronto with 175 000
donation to sick kids hospital very nice
and generous
um Kylie Jenner a million dollars and
Taylor Swift has been donating she
doesn't release the amounts but she now
as of last night has been dming a few
fans who she saw are struggling with
financial
financials and has offered financial
assistance she as far as I see there are
four or five people who she has
personally um venmode or paypaled three
thousand dollars to help them with like
their bills Ariana Grande's doing
something similar for her fans too love
to see it love to see it to me like that
is one of like the kindest ways you can
give back obviously all these donations
are fabulous but like giving it directly
to the people like who are being
impacted like there's something just
about that that feels so personal
personal yeah personal yeah that's the
word Snapchat well said Snatcher
it's beautiful it's beautiful thank you
Anthony also is doing so much for the
cause as always per usual and if you
follow her on Twitter like by the way
it's crazy how much she gets done on
Twitter she's like all right I have one
million masks I need to get them from
Florida to New York I need a trucking
company literally some woman responds oh
my husband owns a trucking company we've
been idle for the last month like you
can have all the trucks like wow it
literally just happens on Twitter it's
crazy following her on Twitter is a
roller coaster that's so amazing I just
want to say a shout out to the truckers
who are getting essential items and
medical supplies across this country I'm
working OT you are amongst the heroes
that we are so thankful for Big Time
like like not sleeping just Go-Go's in
general I feel like they work so hard
away from their families
underappreciated but especially in these
times thank you truckers thank you okay
um we're gonna recap our trust movie of
the day
um which was homecoming with Beyonce and
before I do that you know I would be
I feel like I would get sick you know
I'd feel this like sense of remission
you know like Devastation maybe a sense
of even heartbreak wow yeah
ladies and gentlemen so I don't want to
feel that way so let me just tell you
that this segment is brought to you by
article the easiest way to make your
space look beautiful the direct to
Consumer Furniture Company combines the
curation of a boutique furniture store
with the comfort and simplicity of
shopping online as the weather heats up
and the days get longer article is here
to make your dream patio a reality
jealous with weather resistant dining
sets loungers and sofas article
selection of outdoor furniture makes it
easy to create your patio Oasis in time
for the summer season ugh I'm about to
buy some patio furniture and just like
put it in my living room I don't have a
patio so if you do like Make It Fabulous
please like I have fabulous article
furniture that I've had for over a year
and it hasn't even weathered in the
slightest so I can only imagine that the
outdoor furniture is everything of the
sort if you have patio please make it
fabulous for those of us who can't yeah
and like take fabulous pictures in your
merch and your article Furniture like
just looking glamorous drinking a white
claw
article is full of fast affordable
shipping options and it is available
across the USA and Canada and you get
free shipping on orders of over 999
dollars plus save additional options for
in-room delivery and assembly assistance
which I did all in stock items are
delivered in two weeks or less they have
fair prices where you can save up to 30
over traditional retail prices article
is able to keep their prices low by
cutting out the middleman and selling
directly to you no showrooms no sales
people no retail markups they have they
give you 30 days to make up your mind
with simple returns and exchanges
article is offering our listeners 50 off
their first purchase of 100 or more to
claim visit article.com toast and the
discount will be automatically applied
at checkout that's article.com toast to
get 50 off your first purchase of a
hundred dollars or more sign on make
your patio fabulous okay homecoming with
Beyonce I have so many notes because I
like I understand I absolutely loved it
it was excellent it was a work of art
she's so incredible this performance was
show stopping the attention to detail
the costumes I love the difference in
weekend one versus weekend too when they
went from the yellow to the pink I was
like what the [ __ ] I was like is this a
magic trick I'm like how do they change
so fast no I was like is there a
lighting that changed the colors I was
like so shook and then I realized what
was going on I loved how they just kept
going like back and forth between the
two and think about how well trained
they were that like literally both both
performances a week apart were identical
that they could just cut in the line to
Beyonce singing the same thing fabulous
the outfits were incredible like both
Beyonce's outfits and I love that you
didn't change like 5 000 times yeah she
changed a nice amount of times and I
thought that the band's outfits were
sick oh my God would the girls were they
had the leotard and the hats and the
white boots everything of the sort
killer killer now usually I hate concert
DVDs that cut to like the process the
process because honestly like nobody
cares like just saying but I thought
that it was really important to give
context as to what was going on because
as someone who's never been to an HBCU
homecoming I didn't understand
homecoming I thought it was meant like
she's going back to Houston like is she
from Coachella right so the context was
so important and I love seeing her like
get into shave like that is so relatable
like that she just didn't give birth to
twins and then hop on stage I didn't
even like put all the pieces together
that like how she was in rehearsal she
had just given birth and like she was
snapping back like through the process
of training for Coachella yeah it was
incredible to watch and even in her
first rehearsal when they started
showing her some of the dance moves and
like she just can't get it no no but
like she just moves like so amazingly
she was doing like not even that much
just like shuffling or something she and
it was just like everything yeah and you
know what I felt like this particular
concert sets the bar for the rest of the
world because she was her vocals are
incredible like literally she can't sing
a bad note but then she was giving a
hundred percent of the vocals a hundred
percent of the dancing and then 100 to
the crowd like you can't do well I've
been to concerts where sometimes like
you know Ariana Grande she really have
the presents you know and then it's like
sometimes when I was at Taylor's concert
you relied a lot on back vocal tracks
like Beyonce did not have any of that
like and I hate to compare women against
women all I'm saying is that like she
gave 100 to every element like we
weren't sacrificed like she didn't stop
singing Just because she was dancing and
like by the way she didn't even get out
of breath yeah like she got a little
sweaty at one point I'm like oh that's
it and the amount of like time and
dedication she put into this I don't
know how long the entire process took
but it was like over six months of like
oh yeah every single day in soundstage
is like taking it so seriously and
making it literally like show stopping
yeah like a like a
I don't even know what to compare to
because it's not I feel like when
someone signs up to do a performance
they like you know they rehearse they
come up with like that eight million
dollars like she didn't have to make it
like this huge cultural moment it was
incredible it was incredible um here are
the rest of my notes
um one thing I did not like was how they
kept cutting to like that artsy film
camera that was like Blurry that's like
a new trend and I just don't like that I
can't see I wanna think you have the
high def cameras yeah I want to go into
those what are we going to 1995 Polaroid
like I hate that and it annoyed me but
not enough to make me actually care
um another thing was like I felt like
this was a great opportunity for me to
actually hear a lot of Beyonce's lyrics
and like no I I think I forget that like
a lot of like cultural references come
everything like I sneeze on the beat and
the beat got sick no or I woke up like
this yeah a slay all day like oh yeah
all of this verbiage like comes from her
and I didn't even realize and actually
now it's like been on so many t-shirts
and stuff and it's like oh you're so
tired of seeing it but it's like wow
when she did it the first time it was
like it was iconic yeah and then you
also just get to hear how like funny
some of her lyrics are she's like
talking about Jay-Z in a song He's like
he might be that next Black Bill Gates
and then she said I might be the next
Black Bill Gates and then it makes me
wonder Karen Huger from real houses of
Potomac um it was like a joke in the
first season she said her husband was
the black Bill Gates and then they
literally ended up going bankrupt and I
just wonder if Beyonce took that from
her because Beyonce does watch real
houses in Atlanta so maybe she watch
Potomac or if Karen Huger took that from
Beyonce I have to figure out the
timeline I'm gonna go with Karen from
Beyond but it's possible that Beyonce
could be inspired by Real Housewives
maybe just look at the Timeline she
admitted once that she watches real
houses of Atlanta now the other thing
that I liked was that she made it a real
cultural moment and as someone who
didn't know like about homecoming or
HBCU like it was just so cool to see
someone who's like so [ __ ] proud to
be black like she couldn't be more proud
if she tried and as someone who's like
so proud to be Jewish she like totally
identified with it and then when they
were panning to the crowd and like how
what she was doing on stage was making
people feel like I literally had chills
when she brought out Destiny's Child and
I like and then I was just like taken
back to like that 15 year old girl like
and this is how far she's come like I
literally just I maybe I'm also like
getting my period but I was about to
start crying no by the way same and a
really reminded me when Adele won an
award at the Grammys and she beat
Beyonce and she took it as a moment to
be like Beyonce you have no idea how you
make me feel how your music makes my
black friends feel like I totally got it
like the whole thing like it was just so
like I really had chills the whole time
and like the fact that she just like
wanted so badly for like everyone in the
crowd everyone in the band her entire
band was black women and uh not the
marching band like the Bam Bam like the
guitars
um and like every just everyone on stage
like was just there for like the same
purpose and they totally got like the
cultural importance of it and like now I
got the cultural importance of it like I
just thought it was Sensational like I
I'm I'm there like I get it all like I
just thought it was fabulous it was so
it was so amazing I wish that I had
watched it sooner because I I like this
appreciation that I have for her is now
like this newfound love and I feel like
I've been slowly getting up there but
now I'm like I [ __ ] stand you know
and I get it like I get the cultural
movement like it's just that 100 these
were like even when she sings like old
songs new songs like they're all so good
like when she was singing around the
world girls and it's like now that song
is used for like so much [ __ ] it's
literally used for like commercials for
deodorant so [ __ ] good and true so
true around the world girl so she's like
so proud to be black she's so proud to
be a woman like she's just so proud to
be everything and even when Jay-Z came
on stage and they were singing together
and they were like laughing and having a
good time and like they were just like
Smiley it was it was so [ __ ] cute and
that's never how I've seen their
relationship before no I agree and that
also reminds me a thought that I had was
like so many of the the lyrics
um especially of her more recent songs
like have to do with Jay-Z cheating on
her I'm like you would think that like
she would almost be like embarrassed to
like keep referencing that time in her
life but she just owns all parts of who
she is and I love that like if I can't
imagine like if I had written an album
that I've been cheating on me like I
would never want to sing those songs
again like but no no they're literally
her most popular songs and they're the
best lyrics it's not like he cheated on
me I'm sad it's like empowering it's
like you cheat on me are you [ __ ]
kidding me I'm Beyonce yeah like of
course some [ __ ] goes down when there's
a billion dollars in the elevator yes
that was another line I'm like did she
just say that like there was just so
much happening with like the lyrics and
the dancing and the outfits like it was
just fabulous I love that she brought
out so many guests I usually don't like
that but I just think each guess like
benchmarks like the whole show was just
like a culmination of who she is like
every part of her so like from her
marriage to her family with Solange
Solange is such a good dancer and
Solange's dress was fabulous and then
Destiny's Child she just like owned all
of it and you know what just like
justice for Kelly Rowland Kelly Rowland
is such a good singer and Dancer yeah
that girl Michelle was just like not
carrying her they were all great but it
was reminding me of Jessica Simpson's
book because she like uh did a lot of
stuff with Destiny's Child at the time
like when she was coming up yeah because
they were also all from Texas oh and
they were always so nice to her and it
was just like it was taking me back it
was bringing me into like Jessica
Simpson mode of just like being
emotional and then also in the
flashbacks you got to see who came to
like the after party cardi B was there
sza was there Octavia Spencer oh my God
CJ Walker like it was just fabulous like
she just culminates this like vibe that
you just want to be a part of and it's
like she is an icon and she doesn't have
to lift a finger yet she still works so
hard you know okay and the most
important part of the movie was I think
I couldn't believe like I I would never
be this Brave she literally just right
out of the gate I weighed 218 pounds
when I gave birth to my twins like How
brave are you like I would rather dive
and share my weight everyone knows that
and she's just doing it on Netflix you
know right and then like to one share
that and then two to like Snap back she
looked so her body her body her legs
everything looked so amazing so amazing
like truly I was inspired it was just
truly inspired it was everything of the
sort that was a great choice excellent
choice honestly two hours and 20 minutes
that is my only complaint it was a
little long but there was just so much
there and you know what she was proud of
what she did so she needed two hours and
20 minutes to do it and you know what I
respect it respect the hell out of it
great selection our new selection is
First Wives Club it's on Netflix it's a
classic we've never seen it never seen
it but people have been telling us that
we would love it Diane Keaton is in it
it's like some I don't know why we never
saw it like maybe we got the the
um the tape from Blockbuster and it
broke or something I think like
generationally we were born in like the
four year period where it just was
irrelevant maybe maybe one year too late
yeah okay well I'm really but then like
Ariana Grande references a lot for like
uh you know her last album yes and
Ariana Grande and us have the exact same
cultural references so maybe we'll love
it yeah no for sure but it's like where
we were like a sleep when the movie
popped off I don't even remember it like
coming out when I was a child yeah so
we're watching it's on Netflix I hope
you guys are enjoying enjoying this
toast movie of the day honestly it's
like the one thing that gives me like
something to do yeah no it really does
and it's always it's always nice when
the movie is good so he'll be run and
roll now we're on a bit of a streak we
had self-made we had mad money we had
homecoming yeah sleepover was amazing
you know we're on a good we're on a good
roll last week was rough yeah we didn't
know what like Vibe we were trying to
catch every day yeah and then we
realized every day is different every
day is different and I loved doing a um
a concert DVD I think that was just an
inspired Choice by you oh thank you so
much maybe Sim will do reputation
maybe next week yeah but you should have
one question two on concert a week okay
maybe we should do Katy Perry Part of me
because that's one of my favorite
documentaries okay we'll get to it we're
gonna take like a five second pause
don't go anywhere and we're gonna just
move snatches chair over and then we'll
be right back go get a snack
we're back we're back you guys with the
one and only snatchler yeah we can all
be together I know how you doing snatch
you I've been better are you feeling
snatched no why actually kind of I threw
up this morning so like that that always
helps that always gives you a nice
sweaty glow yeah so you uh weren't able
to join us on the toast even though we
asked you last week because you were
busy working but I according to the
rumor mill things have changed things
have changed um move your mic a little
closer to your mouth yeah I think it's
definitely changed like most of America
I was laid off moving right close to
your mouth and can you see me yeah yeah
okay yes I was laid off um yesterday
yesterday morning
um it [ __ ] sucks but like I'm just
one of a million you know yeah you know
what
um
that was expected you know you were the
newest person you had an entire chance
yeah there were a lot of chaos oh yeah
no it wasn't like a mass layoff it
wasn't just me and it's happening around
the country so you're just one of many
and you know what this is this is our
new life yeah it's crazy yeah but at
least you have you know TNN to fall back
on yeah you have this natural I'm very
fortunate I know that it's just like I
was happy you were really happy but that
happiness doesn't have to stop you know
and you'll get there there will be other
jobs this too shall pass yeah you know
what it's
it's sad because I know you like loved
your job and your friends like you were
just like thriving you were a character
on younger you know yeah no I know but
you'll get back there you know what it's
life has plans you know you never know
in a year from now you'll look back and
be like wow I'm so glad I am where I am
now and it wouldn't have happened if I
didn't get laid off that's true I hope
so and now you could sleep in I know I'm
trying to think of what I should be
doing now because you have an open
invitation to the toast every day this
episode has been so fun with you maybe
you could be doing double duty on
snatchler I could but there's genuinely
not enough to talk about I know because
there's no season there's no season so
I'll think about that I was thinking
maybe starting a YouTube channel oh
maybe now is the time oh my God I love
that oh my God that would be so fun for
the campers yeah it's so hard I know but
I have nothing but time now guys let me
let me pull up things what kind of
content would you want to see from
Margo's YouTube channel oh wow well
obviously like the beauty the beauty and
fitness and course yeah I like I don't
know I just feel like I do that already
yeah you do it on Instagram but you
would just like repackage it differently
and do it on YouTube yeah I have a big
fancy camera you could take it it's
actually right behind you if you want it
it's very expensive I bought it when I
want to start a YouTube channel and that
just didn't pan out for me life had
other plans you know man plan godla yeah
maybe I'll take it I also need to try
tripod like it's a whole investment and
that would like that's a lot of time and
then you could work on that during the
corn stain I know it's just like I don't
know what I'm supposed to do now I know
like work was really keeping me sane and
like you could start applying for jobs
but in this account no one's hiring no
one so like there's nothing for me to
really do yet I would say take the time
invest in yourself invest in this
natural invest in your Instagram invest
in YouTube like keep building your brand
yeah and when when everything bounces
back in one or two months which I really
do believe that it will you'll still get
back out there yeah it's just like
anyone would be lucky to have a snitch
like you thanks yeah what was the what
did you feel were you okay well
I went yesterday was just like a roller
coaster of emotions which is why I ended
up with me being hammered on a live
stream dancing with my sister and then
throwing up this morning like I just
think like that is normal
um I was like devastated like when it
happened I was like this just can't be
real and then I was just like by the way
you like had a feeling that it was going
to be you because you were like saying
two weeks ago that like if they start
having to lay people off that you knew
it was going to be you well yeah I
started five months ago like it's last
Wednesday first one's out that's just
the way the world works yeah
um I thought you were being paranoid but
I was wrong yeah apparently
um and then I was just like so sad I was
like this can't be real I was just
waiting for someone to call me and be
like oh like it was a mistake like
totally like we didn't mean to you and
then I got like the the email like the
agreement thing that you have to sign
and I was like oh [ __ ] they're not
coming back for me this is is happening
um it was just it's such a weird it's
just such a weird thing it's like really
like life-changing and it's just like I
like had so many friends that like I
loved so much so it like feels like a
heartbreak you know yeah and like can
you still hang out with your co-workers
even if you don't work I feel like no no
but if they really became like your
friends like in the Bold type you know
then yeah true so true well now I was
loving watching The Bold type and then I
went and turned it on yesterday and it's
like just triggering now because the
Bull type like was your life yeah but
now it's not it's not
I just feel like the whole takeaway here
shouldn't be like that you feel
discouraged you know because this is
like a once in a lifetime fluke no I
know it's like incredibly bad timing
like yeah but it shouldn't you were
doing so well like the change that we've
seen in you in the last five months it's
just been like a whole new snitch and
the old snitch was so incredible and
then it was even more incredible
fabulous and Sensational right you know
and so I wouldn't let this like stop you
in your personal growth you're just
gonna you're everything of the sore girl
you know you're fabulous you're so
fabulous thank you guys I appreciate it
and we yeah there's a seat for you on
the toast like any day because we love a
snitch on the toast snitch on the toes
one more time
hey snitch on the two I don't think I've
ever seen you spread your legs like that
Jackie you did that earlier too I mean
that's what sitting on the toast it does
to me I don't think you understand like
I don't think anytime I have to edit the
snatcher and I have to put in the snitch
on the snap
I still use ours it's infectious it
really is that's like my theory about
like if you stand in front of the mirror
in a power pose and you say to yourself
good morning Millennials you'll be in a
better mood I totally agree I totally
like we could be in a [ __ ] mood before
we start the show and then we go into
good and all of a sudden and there are
many days where we show up just like not
feeling it you know of course because
that's who we are but then like that
guttural good the cultural good it
brings something out Margo this might
lift your spirits is that I'm reading
the YouTube comments and they are so
positive about your your potentially
starting a YouTube channel they say they
would just watch you sit in front of a
camera like doing anything
oh yeah I know there's so many campers
out there who would love that it's a lot
of work I think and it takes a really
long time to like get actual subscribers
and like and then like to think of like
different concepts like everyone does
the same videos like I know how many
[ __ ] everyday makeup routines can you
film you know one because I have a say
makeup routine yeah and then everyone
all of a sudden has a million so it's
not your everyday yeah they're like
glowy makeup routine New York makeup
like you could do like Vlog but you
could use quarantine stuff like you did
your nails show everyone so you had a
gel manicure that you took off yourself
and then you did that manicure on your
own and I think it looks amazing well it
came out way better now than before like
it was just I colored way outside of the
line but it looks like you got them done
no they don't you can still I you can
still see the gel underneath I didn't
fully take that one well from where I'm
sitting they look fabulous yes that
would have been that would have been
some good content I was losing my mind
you're just an interesting girl you are
you're like the most fabulous you're
smitch in the city yeah don't let this
bring you down seriously I know I have
to work on that but it's okay to be sad
because like you really did like your
job and whatever but don't let it like
deter you it was not Performance Based
like literally the world is in shambles
like this is just it's bigger than me
it's bigger than you exactly yeah no
it's okay to be sad for like a day yeah
yeah and to be drunk yeah positives I'm
done being drunk no I know yeah I think
I'm done like I threw up this morning
okay yeah that was definitely so stupid
yeah that was crazy that was crazy I
can't believe you still came here
um but you got here early well I had
been up since eight you know and you're
like so hung over there also my [ __ ]
work alarm like rang I was like are you
kidding
um but yeah no um it was not good it was
not good but yeah I'm excited to sleep
in now like going forward that's
exciting for me yeah
um but besides that like quarantine's
about to get roll rough yeah it's boring
welcome I I made a suggestion one that
probably didn't go over well when you
were really upset but I think you should
take over the girl with no job Instagram
account for a little while I know
literally I do have a job technically
and you don't I know rub it in says rub
it in well you are also still The
Statler that's true that's true and
there even though it's not the on season
like The Bachelor people are just
hopping off left and right yeah they
never stop they never stop
um someone told me that McKenna
referenced Us in her life yes I watched
it oh what did she say
um someone was like
do you watch the morning toast and she
was like no uh those girls don't like me
like they talk like they talk [ __ ] about
me and I don't need that negativity in
my life that's such my kind of thing to
say 100 so Mike did you stick your
tongue out at the end
um I wasn't looking for it but I don't
think so so like honestly like usually
things like that like would give me a
pit or something but like I stand by
everything I've said about it
someone told literally that she was
something of the sword and that's not
the case that's all I said we always
said honestly yeah they were looking out
for her like literally somebody lied to
her we were just doing her favor
actually Margaret I played categories
over zoom two nights ago and the Word
was uh the letter was m and the category
was villain and I wrote McKenna did it
count like no one was understanding I
was playing with a bunch of boys and
like two girls who just didn't watch The
Bachelorette this season The Bachelor
and I gave myself the point because I
thought it was a really creative idea
but um people were not understanding
yeah I mean it's definitely subjective
that's true yeah it's category
subjective but I think I would have
given that I would have given that I
would have given that we're playing
together because you guys because we all
agree that she was like the villain of
the season but a lot of people don't not
a lot sorry but like my Canada wouldn't
agree with that right actually I don't I
wouldn't even say that she's strong I
have a voice
yeah oh my God you made me realize that
I'm strong I can't oh new um Keeping Up
with the Kardashians is tonight I'm so
excited we got moved to Thursday yes
which is so interesting I think that
that's interesting yeah because they
couldn't keep up with the Sunday nights
no honestly so much happens on Sunday
nights like so many football games so
many award shows like so many holidays
Global moments that I never understood
why they were always on Sunday but I get
like sun it's like a family day and
Sunday like Kardashians is a family show
like I understood that but to be honest
they were just always competing and
nobody I know really watches live maybe
they'll watch live now on Thursday I
never watch live I will be watching live
tonight I'm so excited the clips we've
been getting Courtney and Kim getting
physical looks so ravishing I also just
want to say I want to bring this up
because I genuinely don't want to talk
to YouTube about this but the
Kanye Taylor like I just think that it's
interesting that the week of the
premiere is when it got leaked yeah it
like who leaked it I think that's the
most interesting part of the whole thing
just who leaked it yeah a lot of people
were thinking it was the Kardashian Camp
because they have a Premiere this week
but I don't know what reigniting this
Feud does for Kim and sorry Kim is just
as relevant before this league and after
I just feel like something big happens
with the Kardashians like literally
every month and so then once a year that
month falls on the same month as a
premiere of a show like even when Jordan
and Tristan happened that was like right
before the show was about to Premiere
and people were like oh my God Chris set
it up like no I think when you're just
that interesting like interesting
interesting things happen to you all the
time right and when you're literally the
epicenter of Paul culture like every now
and then there's gonna be news about you
just because it coincides with the
premiere of your show like that's
nobody's business yeah but sometimes
it's definitely yeah planted but you can
feel when it is this didn't feel that
way totally well snatchler thank you for
sharing your news with everyone I think
that people are grateful for the
transparency well because I knew people
were like we're gonna start noticing and
then like would like DM me and ask me so
like I just can't and I was like I hate
hiding things on social media I can't
hide anything from The Toasters anyway
so I try yes so true so you're gonna be
fine and thanks for being positive about
it I think people appreciate that as
well yeah yeah
you got a good head on your shoulders
kid trying anytime you're ready to take
TNN back full time we are always a spot
for you on the Stitch cam I appreciate
that Mom wish we were leaving you with
better news but we'll be back tomorrow
Friday and then next week we are back
all week at 12 o'clock Eastern time so
make sure you're following the morning
to us we go live Monday through Friday
10 30 a.m Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
everyone subscribe we need the
subscribers we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
so you subscribe to us on iTunes Spotify
Stitcher public radio iHeartRadio
castbox anywhere you get podcasts
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning toast leave a five star
review about a beautiful stunning and
smart we are thank you Mario everyone
follow Margo on Instagram at margashray
yes for updates on potential YouTube
channel listen to the snatcher for all
of her opinions on everything also
there's brand new TNN content out so if
you're looking for a new episode of
maternity live is today today yesterday
we got a new episode of mood with Lauren
Elizabeth she's sitting down with Jackie
Schimmel from the [ __ ] sesh podcast no
[ __ ] Bible podcast and then there's
also a new episode of uh caviar dreams
with Margaret Josephs where she's
sitting down with her friend Dorothy
who's the executive producer of real
houses of New Jersey so if you're a big
Housewives fan you're gonna love that
all available on uh Spotify and iTunes
thank you guys so much we will see you
tomorrow
oh